you guys ready to get madder than you've
ever been
yeah oh okay i'm looking at it already
why don't you why don't you read that
headline ian
you want me to okay
you go all the way by the administration
asks cbp officers to leave southern
border for ukraine according to new
memory
you have got to be kidding me
this is this is the type of stuff that
that
makes me want to go crazy because
it makes you why first of all
how
you look at that headline and you can't
even begin to wrap your head around it
we don't even have enough people at the
southern border this has been an issue
for what a year now
and you're pulling them to go to ukraine
or asking volunteers and and it's and
it's because they want so it's it's
mostly poland they want they want these
troops in poland processing uh ukraine
refugees or migrants it's just
let me read a little bit they say
the biden administration is asking cbp
officers to voluntarily deploy to poland
following russia's invasion of ukraine
after being selected volunteers will
deploy within two or three days and work
in europe for at least one month
they say the off the office of field
operations is seeking volunteers to
assist with the possible evacuation of
u.s citizens lawful permanent residents
and their immediate family members in
ukraine he reads a memo sent to the
agency's field operations executives and
obtained by just the news so i don't
want to immediately be like oh you know
shake my fist we got to get americans
out of ukraine we got to get permanent
residents we got to get you know anyone
who's helping us we can't let this be
another afghanistan foreign do we need
the border patrol here in america doing
that job to leave the already in
shambles southern border i feel like we
have plenty aspects of our military that
could cover that job absolutely you know
i i i think i think military police
could probably do that um
just to name a few and i i i i'd like to
to present you with my vision of how
this came about
and and
so you've got joe biden and kamala
harris and they're in a room
and someone comes in you know and
they're like mr president the situation
in ukraine is very serious we're going
to need personnel to evacuate american
citizens permanent permanent residents
and biden goes oh oh oh no oh we have to
open the southern border now because cbp
is the only one who can do it and
they're like no mr president we don't
have to oh oh jeez you forced my hand
all right send cbp off the border and
send him to ukraine the only people that
understand borders is the border patrol
i was thinking yesterday i actually
tweeted it out if we a war with russia
is actually a war with russia and china
and if that happened we wouldn't be
complaining about china invading taiwan
we'd be complaining about them invading
our southern border through mexico do
not eff around with this uh
can we coin the term for like the russia
china alliance you know because like
history will remember the name of the
they're going to call them like you know
like the axes of evil or something
sino-rus
how about like the the the um
the evil avengers i can't even bring
myself to call my team to call them evil
like the good and evil narrative is
broken down we've been america's been
putting weapons and military bases in
people's face for a hundred years this
is insane and then they invade iraq this
is the country of freedom the one that
liberated cuba from the spanish empire
and gave it autonomy and independence we
fought a war to give cuba independence
not to conquer it and then we go into
iraq and afghanistan we give the rest of
the world carte blanche you can't sit in
a country and let the government conquer
say nothing and not expect other
countries to start conquering we are the
example
so it's it's it's it's all the same it's
propaganda the us and afghanistan the
u.s in iraq and then they go oh i can't
believe that russia would invade ukraine
get out of iraq
get out of iraq right now get out man
get out and do it safely god get out
this is what i tweeted and it was it was
a multi-faceted tweet i said i'm gonna
start an organization called anti-war
and we're we're going to claim to oppose
war but we'll actively support any war
that we're engaged in because we're
engaged in a war for the sake of
stopping war so our war is justified and
then everyone was like you're describing
the united states and antifa at the same
time and i'm like yeah yeah
like
the us is uh justified and engaging in
its conflicts you know what you know
what the issue is it's the same players
pointing their fingers at each other
over and over again i mean who was in
afghanistan before we were it was the
russians the soviet union
it's back and forth and back and forth
and and
when you're when you're playing that
game it har it's hard to point the
finger because we we don't have any
right to say anything because we we've
been invading territories
for our own reasons we had we had
weapons of mass destruction was the
first reason that turned out to be a big
lie and then next thing you know we're
in how many countries in the middle east
you know and then we're pulling out
recklessly and and then you want to
point your finger and it's it's not to
say that that what putin is doing is
right it's not but
we can't be the moral high ground of the
world if we don't have a moral high
ground to stand on
yeah uh so you know when people are
talking about why we should not get
involved in ukraine
i comply i agree like we shouldn't you
know to a certain extent we can be we
obviously have to protect uh our allies
in the baltic states to a certain degree
i don't even know how much we want to
get involved in that if things you know
truly go south because not even our
border but we do have allies the
challenge though i think is
it may be inevitable whether whether we
want to or not you look at what happens
in world war ii eventually you get
dragged into it now yeah
you could ignore it you know you could
say okay well we're not getting involved
in ukraine but what happens when ukraine
falls and that russia moves what does
putin do next
you know so
we poland's not going to be sitting
they're not going to be happy about that
yeah we've become entangled in all these
relationships because we wanted to go
out and be the world police we wanted to
go out and put all these weapons
facilities all over the world and you
know spread spread freedom by force
and look where it gets us you know how
how much better off is the american
public over the past 60 70 years that
we've adopted this world police sort of
mentality you know what has it done for
the average american citizen yeah quote
unquote it's guaranteed our safety but
you know you can't even measure that you
can't measure what you've actually
stopped i don't feel very safe right now
but the the what is the cost of the
average american citizen we have what 30
trillion dollars in debt how much how
much of that is war debt
you know from from us being the world
police from us funding nato from us
funding all these alliances and acting
like we're supposed to be
you know regulating everybody's behavior
around the world it's it's a novel or
excuse me it's it's a noble cause but
how how successful have we been and at
what cost nobody nobody wants to be the
one to back down you know uh
when i was when i talk about say antifa
and the woke far left
actually i'll i'll i'll i'll present you
the the conundrum
the culture wars rap is rampaging on
would you be willing to give up free
speech and the first and second
amendments to have peace with antifa
that's a good question like i i say
antifa but you know the far left of
course not never there's no compromise
there that's that even even if it would
come at peace because it's it's it's
peace it will cost kind of deal because
what what comes after that piece and so
what happens with a country like ukraine
is people you know they say things like
we should just not have the war you need
to like we should do and it's like i
know
it's
yes we don't want war and it's really
easy to say but you've got russia
vladimir putin looks at what's going on
there and he says
i will not tolerate the us coming in and
i mean you look at what happened it's
not even it's not it's the west it's
nato it's eu you look what happened in
2014 with the protest there with
yanukovych putin views ukraine as
already conquered by the u.s yanukovych
was ousted
pro-pro-america politicians get get get
put in
pro-west politicians and then he's like
i'm not going to tolerate that's a red
line for me so he says we're going to go
in and we're going to we're going to get
rid of this western influence the united
states says the exact same thing about
russia vladimir putin wants to rebuild
the soviet union he's trying to build up
the russian trade federation he wants
ukraine as well we're battling over
ukraine and the question as with
yanukovych was you know who's he gonna
side with where's the country going to
go
neither side is willing to give up that
territory the bread basket of europe
thus you get war now let me just throw
it back to the original we're no better
off than we were 70 years ago 80 years
ago during the cold war right we're
right back in that same scenario well
let's let's throw it to to this this the
start of the segment and to what i think
matters substantially more
when you have the bite administration
asking cbp officers to leave our
southern border
they do not care about this country
right and they are asking the united
states of america to sacrifice blood and
treasure
for for people in a far away land this
is sorry go ahead i was going to say i i
i
shouldn't we secure our own oxygen map
could you imagine being one of the first
people that volunteered to go to vietnam
because you didn't know what what was
actually coming waiting for you over
there yeah those people like the people
volunteered happily in the beginning
because they didn't realize because they
bought all the propaganda lydia i'm
sorry i felt like i interrupted you i
was just gonna say this to me seems like
such insult to injury for joe biden to
stand up there and say we're gonna have
to make sacrifices who's really making
sacrifices here is it joe biden the
middle class it's my middle class and
only in the middle class yeah i mean
it's the it's the poverty like middle
class and down yeah when i say when i
say middle class i mean everybody
because to us it or to them to them it's
it's everybody except them look at look
at these like blue check elites who are
like we have to intervene it's like i've
got an application right here for you to
sign up yeah how old are you you're 55
well if you can hold a gun i thought you
asked a really interesting question
what's putin going to do next and that's
like i've been thinking a lot this came
up a couple days ago and was worth
repeating that when hitler invaded
poland he was doing it in his he said
because they were after world war one
the treaty of versailles split a piece
of germany off gave it to poland and
then the polish government was executing
and creating committing genocide on
these former germans now polish so
hitler was going to liberate that area
and bring peace back to those germans
putin's saying a similar thing with uh
ukraine post-soviet they're russian um
there's a genocide going on he actually
said that in his declaration uh
yesterday
i don't know if there's a genocide going
on the the u.s news has been completely
silent i've never heard an inkling that
there might be a genocide going on in
ukraine it's different it's not out of
the realm of possibility no no it's
different i would i would say i think
the ukrainians learn their lesson about
russian control from the hall of demore
and probably are not too keen to be you
know involved in something like that but
when we're if we're drawing parallels
russia doesn't need to be germany in
this china can be
it's it's you know history doesn't
repeat it runs right because china does
have
rainy and hitler kind of fed off each
other one would invade a little bit then
the other would be like oh okay i guess
that means it's okay for me to take and
they're like really well then i'm gonna
take a little bit more here then i'll go
into poland here so if the russians take
a little piece the chinese
psychotic racist han supremacist
mentality might because putin's not a
psychotic racist hitler was but the ccp
they strike me as psychotic racists well
they got the uyghur muslims in
concentration this is also american
propaganda i'm getting this fed to me
from the americans but that's what it
seems like it's not just the americans
reporting on what's happening with the
weaker muslims and you've also got yeah
that's an established fact that that i
mean that's like open massacre on these
people so yeah you know we're we're not
without sin but you know i think there's
uh there's a certain level of sinister
behavior that's going on
with within the chinese government that
is is beyond
you know what we're talking about
everybody else thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you